there's a lot of people especially in
the 1990s people used to say hmm maybe
the 21st century will have five
superpowers maybe it'll have seven now
maybe it'll be three but then it will be
a few beneath them or they'll leave one
America on top and a set of regional
powers on the world is not really that
clean and tidy it's not going to fit
into an org chart like that I I simply
believe that a superpower has to have
influence everywhere in the world all
the time round the clock and be able to
to change the way people think and the
way they act and the way they decide
what they're going to do anywhere in the
world and the only three powers that can
do that
are these Imperial systems or super
powers which are America the European
Union and China Russia doesn't do that
anymore
and it can't it has large nuclear
stockpile of course but it's not about
to launch war on Argentina and it
otherwise doesn't affect the policies of
South America but Europe does and China
does Islam doesn't do that it isn't a
coherent superpower India isn't yet
there and may never be there and so I
took that sort of you know hierarchy and
I said there's only really three that
meet the test of what a superpower is
and what always has been and those are
those three that's why I focused on them
it's not so much about emphasizing that
these are three mutually exclusive
competitive monolithic superpowers it's
not France versus Germany versus Britain
versus Russia you know in the 18th and
19th centuries it's much more about
these three Imperial systems that are
setting the rules or making their own
rules and competing with each other
either in hard or soft ways all the time
now you mentioned some interesting
things will
in addition let me pause and kind of
gather my thoughts there are several
reasons why not to include India
initially first it's the time horizon
I'm dealing with the dawn of the 21st
century and the countries or the empires
that already are superpowers and are out
there muscling their way to influence
all over the world India's not yet doing
that it's just
starting to find its feet and figure out
what it wants to do unfortunately you
might be coming too late like in
business you've got first mover
advantage in geopolitics and China is
out there eating India's lunch
everywhere where India wants to have
influence Afghanistan Central Asia Iran
Burma China is already there it's
already seizing the resources there
areas where they'll cooperate like in
Africa where they kind of team up a
little bit and they promote their
business interests and everyone it's a
big pie and everyone sharing their there
sort of you know getting a piece of it
but on the whole India is constrained in
ways that China isn't and that is a
permanent fact the fact is that India is
a peninsula surrounded by you know water
on three sides and there's limits to how
far it can project itself across water
it's also surrounded by the world's
tallest mountain range the Himalayas
beyond which it's difficult to project
influence then there's the fact that all
of its neighbors are either failed
States or enemies like Pakistan Nepal
Bangladesh or Sri Lanka so you there are
a lot of built-in constraints that India
faces in how much influence it can have
outside its own country